FOR FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRTEENTH
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER MADDEN
OFFICIALLY VISOR AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDED TODAY'S PERSON
IS BEING MADE AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MATTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM. LARA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE'S
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS. THIS YEAR WICKS HERE WE
HAVE A FORM OKAY WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA WAIT JOINT WILL
SIXTY ONE EIGHT FIFTEEN TO
BERMAN ASSEMBLY CONTINUES WORK
PAST TWELVE MIDNIGHT. IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA I
WAS LIKE TO REMOVE. CONSENT. I
SECOND OKAY. ALL RIGHT THEY
WILL MOVE THE SITE EVERY WILL
JUST TREATED AS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
ITEM MOST OF THE- SECOND MOVERS
FROM THE SECOND ONE IS WORKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MAN
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM NO CARILLO. HI FOR
HILL AYE. HELLO FLORA NOW
GRAYSON GRAYSON I'D
KAMLAGER-DOVE. YEAH CAM HUNDRED
UP I AM MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS THOUGH MATHIS NOW
WORKS OVER. QUIRK SILVA NOT. HI.
I RAMOS RAMOS IRATE RIVAS RIVAS
AYE WORKS WHICH SIDE. OKAY THAT
THE MOTION PASSES AND THIS
RULES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH